I'm constantly wake up every day with
sherry and I'm just like why the [ __ ]
are you with me
like you could be literally be with
whoever you wanted and you chosen me ed
sheeran getting candid about his
personal life like I'm saying all of the
things that I think are wrong with me
but you still want to be with me and I
just find that amazing and finally
confirm E and E and Jerry Seaborn are
married she's someone's gonna hear that
they're married and I didn't know how
that would be construed for obviously
it's already come out it happened in
this new interview ad posted to his
YouTube page when Charlemagne the god
brought up Ed's new collab with Eminem
and 50 Cent's calls remember the name in
your verse you talk about people
invading your private life and you
started to go a little Eminem on the
blogs or never just a little bit if it's
actually before me and cherry got
married and I knew that we'd be married
by the point that the song came out IDI
posted this shot of the pair last
January confirming his engagement but
he's always been private about cherry
though he did talk about her a little in
his Apple music documentary yeah that
was that was a surprise to watch it I
was like oh god is this should this
happen but it's fine so like having
cherry in it didn't seem like it fit for
me but it does in the grand scheme of
things in the new interview and also
talks about his process of writing love
songs these days
I've done thinking out loud I've done
perfect I've done the love songs about
finding different angles now to do
[Music]
he also chats about all the other clubs
on his new album number six
collaborations projects including RTV
and I just I love how unfiltered she is
literally she's meet so media trained
not to be media trained you know like
her whole shtick is she goes on and says
whatever she wants and that is what
works for the worst I never had a media
training either and I feel like I get to
just say what I want and she's
successful because she is who she is
she's there's no one else that can be
cardi B and what he hopes this album
does for his career the factors of like
I've already achieved more than I
thought okay mm-hmm so right now I'm at
a point where I'm just having fun
[Music]